الى موسكو الان معنا هناك مراسلنا مازن
عباس مازن اهلا بك بالرغم اذا من
الاتهامات بالتبادل القصف مسكت تقول انها
تحترم هذه الهدنه هل من تعليمات ربما اعلن
عنها في حال عدم التزام الجانب الاوكراني
وهمم تكرار عمليات القصف التي تتهم بها
وزاره الدفاع الجانب الاوكراني
همم ولكن وصلت دفاع اليوم تحدث عن قيام
بها التصدي
له هجوم اوكراني على عده محاور في الجنوب
وايضا في محور دانيسك وانها نجحت في
القضاء على عشرات الجنود الاوكران وايضا
اليات ومعدات عسكريه ولكن هذا البيان لم
يذكر تماما متى تم هذا الصدام العسكري
قبل قبل
عن بعد لكن سلطات بشكل
عام
همم نفذته القوات الاخرانيه بمدافع همم
في همم ضد حي بتراسكي في العاصمه يعني ايه
عاصمه اقليم دانيلز همم ولو اصفر عن تدمير
همم بعض المباني وكان ذلك يعني بعد عقب
همم همم موعد همم بدايه الهدنه لذلك هناك
بالتاكيد ترى التردد اتهامات بان هناك من
ينتهي في الاذن ولكن لم تعلم مسكو كيف
يمكن ان تتصرف او وتتعامل مع الضربات
الاخرانيه في خلال هذه ال 36 ساعه القادمه
يجري الحديث عن زياره موعوده لبوتين الى
القوه الروسيه همم في الجانب الاخرين
بالطبع هل من مؤشرات على احتمال حدوثها
بالتزامل مع عيد الميلاد الاردن
الخبراء العسكريون لا يستبعدون اكيد مثل
هذه الزياره خلال الساعات القادمه وان
كانت مثل هذه الزياره
بشكل تقريبي موعدها ولكن لا شك ان سواء
يعني عبر اعلان الهدنه بمناسبه اعياد
الميلاد لا شك انه يريد ان يدعم هذه
الخطوه التي تشكل كارت سياسيا هاما ليس
فقط على مستوى تهدئه قلق الراي العام
الروسي همم
والذي ازداد قلقه بعد الخسائر البشريه
الكبيره خلال فتره السابقه ولكن ايضا كي
يقدم للعالم همم السياسه الروسيه
باعتبارها ساعيه لايقاف القتال والاستئناف
المفاوضات وان لم يرفض والجانب الاوكراني
ولذلك مثل هذه الخطوه تدعم همم هذا
التقديم للبوتين والسياسات الكبرلين ولا
يستبعد العديد من الخبراء مثل هذه يعني
شكرا لك على هذه المعلومات من موسكو
مراسلنا مازن عباس